姐那天我都不敢穿短一点的裤子
因为你太白了
你看我给你比下两个
两个人总感觉是好吧
我是真的遗传
一直都那么白
是不是觉得你瘦的可以吗
不会晒伤
会晒红
晒伤晒脱皮
脱皮一阵
然后会痛
然后过一阵子就白
就是白白比较对紫外线没有保护力
所以就会很容易晒伤
真的没办法的话
还是得要去海边
可是就是一到室内我就有点怀抱安全
我也比较喜欢那种防晒的皮肤上面的感觉
对对对
好恶心
没事
主要是他需要这个主机
是主机
后面是需要结合例句
人漂亮就是最美的风景
哈哈哈哈哈
超漂亮
说那我的我的背景就不人人人这是最美的背景的
是超漂亮哦
这边都可以了可以了可以了啊
其实我感觉刚刚您拿着这个bgm进场的时候就好甜的感觉甜吗
就感觉在你身上有个很轻便轻松的感觉
进来好的
那姐姐先跟我们镜头打个招呼好吧
哈喽大家好
我是cindy王心凌
哈喽欢迎小溪姐姐
其实刚才我们在电梯里还说呢
就是提到您感觉就是青春的代名词
真的而且还是我们那时候时尚标杆是吗
对我们都全班女生都想剪你的同款发型
就很潮嘛呀刘海啊是的
所以我们也很好奇
就姐姐您的这个青春回忆是什么样的
我的青春回忆啊
你的歌曲我会听张学友啊
林忆莲啊
王菲啊
嗯啊小学的时候那个时候还有草蜢啊
哦你知道唐萌吗
我知道我知道我就放心了
因为确实就感觉就姐姐您说那些呃歌手啊
其实我们也有听
但是确实主要是听你的作品长大的
我是听他们作品的
对对长大的
因为刚才我还说就记得我们那个时候班上比如说搞文艺汇演啊
肯定要跳爱你肯定要跳睫毛弯弯这些对
哎那您想的就是您青春当中印象最深刻的一首歌是什么
选一首只能选一首很难吗
选一首嗯
ok我来说嗯
因为我小时候呢我小时候也是会自己存钱买那种小卡带来听的不对
那我的第一张cd我记得是在我中学刚小学刚升中学的时候
第一张cd买的是张学友的文笔哦
我别对我和你们毕生的
对对对
那时候我小学刚升中学
那时候就是我本人也是经历了卡带
然后到cd的这个这个这个这个阶段这样子
所以我的第一张cd就是张学友的吻别嗯
所以这首歌可以让你回忆回忆起自己的青春是吗
对
虽然好像小学中学听这首歌有点成熟
但是因为那个时候其实也不太懂
不是这么了解歌词的意思
可是就觉得旋律很好听
然后学友哥唱歌很好听
然后对
所以这个是我基于那个时候的记忆
因为我觉得从买卡带到买cd的这个阶段
就是一个蛮值得纪念的一个回忆
好的哎
其实呃我们看节目的时候啊
感觉姐姐你前两期节目可能讲话比较少一点
但是后面看到你当队长之后啊
又感觉好开了
没办法
当队长不得不说话
不是这样的
我是比较慢热的人
我是比较慢热
然后再一个比较不熟悉的状态中
而且那个拍摄真的是真的是只有厕所跟睡觉的时候
可以把镜头遮掉哦
真的就是大家1年在宿舍住个五天
就是24小时都有浸透的那种对
所以在那个状态下
我本来就是一个比较慢热的人
但我但我不是不热
所以我就会顺其自然慢慢慢慢来到后来当队长没有办法
因为你当队长了
你就一定要把大家整合好好团结起来
落在同一条线上
然后要呃要要催促大家
要叮咛大家一起练习呀什么的
那您会有点社恐吗
比如说就是第一次跟不熟的人相处啊什么的
会有这种感觉吗
我觉得我好像还不至于社恐
就是骂你这种就是慢热一点
那当队长和就是普通的队员有没有什么区别
就感觉上呃就是肩膀会重一点
就是要呃就是不不能只是做好
因为当队员的话
就是每个人会有每个人负责的部分是唱歌的part
跳舞的part就是要把那个部分负责好
可是当队长的时候
有时候像我们会有选歌的环节呀
然后或是在更早期就是挑选队员的环节
就是要去想象
要去排兵布阵
然后选歌的时候也要去想说考量的状态已经不是说我自己喜欢什么歌
我适合什么歌
而是团队以平均来说怎么样的歌适合大家
然后我们做怎样的呈现会是最有优势的
所以考量的角度都不太一样
嗯那当队长是是您自己就是民事自愿的
还是说就是被动的被动
我是我是被动被被动被投票的
但是呢就是既然当队长就还是我就还是当仁不让
就是但是就很谢谢大家投我了
在自己在被投喂
当队长的那个单客
也是觉得
啊好好吧
就就就尽力
就是在当队长的那一刻
心态就是角度就就就即刻转换
那我觉得其实姐姐你很适合当队长诶
真的很适合我看节目里面
包括呃抢人的时候啊对吧
还有带大家排练的时候
就是看节目
我觉得就嗯姐姐很适合他们
好像节目组好像也是这样说
就是我的队友队员们好像也是这样说
但我自己就是嗯嗯就是也是在这个过程中在在尽力的尽力
在也是在学习当副队长
就是这样
当队长就真的必须要把大家沟通协调好
队员比较可以天马行空对
然后可是队长就必须要比较理性一点
把大家抓在同一条线上
那些最容易还可以吧
还可以啊
很满意啊
我也不知道
就是要看看我的队友们满不满意的好
那其实就是咱们在跟队员相处的时候啊
就那么多姐姐
有没有你特别佩服的
我最佩服我这一组吗
嗯这一组也可以
就是就这么多姐姐当中嘛
就是说我嗯很欣赏的好吧
我很欣赏
我很欣赏谭维维
是因为上海吗
他是我的前队长嘛
就是在二公的时候
他是我的队长
因当然是因为上海的相处
所以我很欣赏他
我觉得他唱歌的部分
这个就我们毋庸置疑
我们这个大家都看到的实力唱将
就是他在音乐音乐素养上
他有一定的专业的这个专业度在之外
可是他也很能够去
接受不一样的意见
然后去整合他
我觉得这个这个部分我是很欣赏的
就是他的内外在我都觉得很欣赏
他看起来就酷酷的嗯
不是就是说他是谭大哥嘛
真的但是其实他内心好柔软哦
他好感性
他看起来应该是我比她爱哭
对不对
其实他比我爱哭
她在节目里面就是非常非常就是外刚内柔的那种
对我反而是不爱在镜头面前哭的那种
可是他是非常感性的
我看弹幕说的就是我就是谭维维唱歌喜欢用眼神杀那种感觉
所以我对他会有眼神杀
所以我好像哦原来会长沙是不是好好哦
上台我要杀回去就能解开一下
想杀一杀
但是就买这个表演表演方式很适合这首歌
还是很喜欢这种
我蛮喜欢这首歌的
好的嗯
和哪位姐姐接触会比较多一点
但是我自己的我自己的队员接触一定是最多的
因为我们除了线上的
大家看得到的那些练习和相处之外
雾霾还有很多的舞蹈
复杂的舞蹈要做排练
所以我们线下几乎也是每天碰面
因为每天都会做训练
嗯
其实最熟悉的肯定是他们的几年
她很认真很努力
他不需要人家操心
会把自己分内的事情做好
而且他是很积极的
想要做好他自己的那个舞台呈现
甚至表情表情管理呃
跟音乐上的配合这些他是很主动
很积极的一个认真的态度
那阿sa很聪明啊
eq很高
阿娇有时候有点会在自己的小宇宙小食节
然后有时候又会回到现实
跟我们一起
就是也是一个很善良很可爱的女生啊
天爱小爱很贴心
有时候会像小秘书这样让小秘书帮帮帮这个帮那个
然后个性也是很拼
也是很愿意花时间跟大家一起努力
一起练习的女生
嗯
那总而言之
其实对内相处就非常的快乐
非常和谐
我们对蛮蛮大家相处处的是蛮好的
我觉得好的诶
其实每一个公演的舞台我都看了
我个人是非常喜欢的
三公嘛
哦都看了对三公就目前是三公嘛
更新到呃
我看了您和谭维维一起合作的山海就真的很绝非常绝
因为他认为是那种比较强硬一点的那种感觉
但是您的话就柔和嘛
就真的就是一山和义海的那种配合
但是你就是如果说每个舞台都那么惊艳的话
你后面舞台会不会有压力啊
不会呀
嗯嗯不会啊
就是其实其实我们已经做到武功了
嗯其实每个舞台都不太一样
其实每个舞台都不太一样
就是说不会是你想想的那种角度去想这件事情对
主要还是看每一次节目组给出来的歌
然后以及赛制我们能够选到怎么样的歌
然后从现有的歌里头
然后跟可以选到的歌里头去做不一样的舞台变化其实是假的对
因为就主要歌曲还是由节目组做决定的嘛
然后也不是说节目组决定了之后
我们想选哪一首
这个赛季就可以让我们选到哪一首
就有时候像觉得三公也是会有一个意外的美丽的一种
大家嗯会感觉好像不是这么觉得
没有这么适合各自队的这个呃一个美丽的结果吧
嗯一个惊喜
但是美丽的结果大家其实都很努力的把它完成的
我觉得嗯我自己身在其中
我自己觉得大家已经很努力的把它完成的很好
那姐姐你最喜欢的舞台风格是什么样的
包括之后理想呈现什么的舞台风格呢
我们现在还是要把我们自己
因为接下来就是决赛嘛
嗯其实还是比较focus在呃决赛的舞台上
包含在我们访问之前看决赛的
有一些歌曲刚好来了
所以刚才我也听了一下歌曲
可是这就不太好
不太好透露
所以其实也呃现在其实重心就还是放在浪姐的录制上面
那浪姐录制的舞台其实每个舞台真的都不太一样
我觉得每个姐姐都会希望有不同的呈现啊
节目组其实也会很努力的让大家看到不一样的舞台
嗯嗯在您知道您要参加这个乘风破浪三的时候
您第一想法是什么
就咱们参加这个节目的初衷是什么
可以讲一下吗
哦我觉得就是希望能够有更多不一样风格的舞台呈现
因为我觉得浪姐三会有让表演者有更大的表演空间
然后很多不一样的舞台
对那有一些舞台可能比如说你刚才说印象很深刻的伤害对
可能就比较不会是呃
比较实比较目前来说比较少有机会出现在我自己个人的演出里头
然后可是可以借由这个呃浪姐的舞台
可以有跟很多不一样的姐姐
然后做合作跟尝试
所以说您在这个节目
因为节目名字叫乘风破浪嘛
其实就是发现我们姐姐们各自很多不同的可能
您觉得您在这个节目当中发现了您以往不一样的可能吗
我觉得我在这个节目当中让大家发现了不一样的王心凌啊
那新闻姐姐这么多歌啊
其实我最喜欢的一首就是我可能以以前喜欢安妮啊
金毛弯弯
但是我现在最喜欢的一首其实是大年
嗯嗯嗯
那么像这首歌在您唱出他的时候
或者说你收的这首歌的时候
你的内心想法是什么呢
其实当时选的就是主要我们是从音乐出发
先选这个旋律
我觉得你小时候喜欢爱你
现在喜欢打雷
肯定是因为在生活在感情上有所情敌
所以会引起你一些共鸣
就是您的歌一直可以唱出
咱们就是女孩子的心事的那种感觉对就我自己在做专辑
在做作品的时候
我们想的也是就是嗯我的歌曲我希望是能够陪伴我的歌迷的
不管是在开心或是不开心
伤心难过嗯
还是就是说不管你在什么阶段
都能够有一首歌能够陪伴你
比较近期的像我今今年年初刚做完高雄巨蛋的演唱会对
然后
哦我自己蛮喜欢那场演唱会的
我觉得蛮好看的
然后也很希望嗯期待接下来可以早一点能够有新的新的演唱会
新的巡演再带给大家
诶说到这个新的演唱会这个事儿了
就是咱们粉丝呼吁的什么巡演啊
演唱会啊
这种包括新专辑啊这种嗯咱们接下来有安排吗
会朝这个方向安排
但我不想跟他们说太多
因为他们的位置逼我们
那你们就是乖乖等着就等着再长一点
乖巧一点
乖乖等着
慢慢的都有
再慢慢的进行
现在是得先把呃浪姐先好好做完
因为也是重视这个舞台嘛
其实最近的心里都还是放在浪姐的舞台嗯
好诶那其实咱们的粉丝对您这个节目的表现讨论得非常热烈啊
就初舞台之后
大家都说你一票我一票心灵80还唱跳
对于这样的玩笑话
就是你会怎么回应啊
或者说你们舍得吗
我80岁还在唱跳
你们真的是我可太爱你爱你
如果如果真的只要我到80岁唱跳舞
还有那个提议的话
我会继续努力保持
到那个时候还可以唱票给大家
那甜心教主就被爱称为甜心奶奶
我80岁的应该是变甜心奶奶了吧
那你会开心吗
如果这么叫你的话
没有什么好不开心的
80岁还可以被叫甜心奶奶
不是一件蛮开心的事吗
其实我觉得就是每一个人心中都有甜美可爱的一面
包含男生对
不管是男生的女生
心中都有一个小男孩
有一个小女孩
只是你把她藏在心里面的哪一个位置
嗯那你觉得就是刚才咱们都说要甜到80岁
你觉得这个甜美你想给他80岁
80岁啊
好啊都可以啦
反正你们我也不知道我爸是社会是什么样子
但我觉得如果心态没有变
我觉得那个甜应该是心态嗯对不是你刻意要去做的一个钱的样子
到80岁还还无法做自己亲自蛮辛苦的
我觉得是心态
就是你心态能够保持那样子的开心开朗的状态
嗯所以您觉得这个甜美和年龄之间会有很大关系吗
他们并不冲突啊
甜美也可以独立
也可以坚强
也可以有个性
对不对
然后我刚刚也讲说
我觉得每个人心中其实都有一个小男孩
小女孩
不管你到几岁
所以就是有时候会不是爸爸妈妈会讲说家有一宝
家有一老
如有一宝
因为有时候就是爷爷奶奶
其实有时候有年纪越大的时候
你会觉得他反应越像孩子
很可爱
对其实每一个人心中都有一个小男孩跟小女孩嗯
这么多年的保田秘诀是什么
可以咱们分享一下吗
其实我没有刻意保甜诶
其实我没有
我觉得是心态
刚才讲的就是
我好像我其实就是这个心态
这个样子就是我与生俱来的一个部分
其实我觉得这个甜必须要由内而发
它不能是你刻意去对去做
那那就不是钱了
那就不是钱了
那呃如果要分享我保持生活和健康的一个方式
我就是会保持运动
我会一直保持着呃长时间呃
很固定频率的
那你知道吗
年过30
接下来的30岁之前
妈妈生给你
30岁之后
自己就要好好保养跟保持女生你就要多敷脸
哪对不对
可是我觉得内在的保养也很重要
就是30岁之后可能新陈代谢会开始变卖
所以你需要靠呃一个很routine的这个运动去去
让你身上的新陈代谢是一直保持着的
所以你就可能还是可以吃喜欢吃的东西
你还是呃可以拥有好的肌肉
好的状态去面对你的工作
好的体力
好的体能嗯
那关于咱们这个保养方面就有没有点小秘诀可以分享美容保养
他就说嗯敷脸哪没事就服
有空的话
那等于说就是每天都要服这样
其实我也没有勤劳到每天
但是我知道我身边的姐姐
有姐姐是每天早一片晚一片面膜
但我也没有勤劳到这
但是就是有时间有空就就可以敷敷脸
但保湿我其实如果没有苏联的话
保湿我也会蛮注重的
在乘风破浪之前
姐姐您在忙什么呢
来之前在做新专辑的收割
也开了好几次会
然后就是决定来浪姐嘛
然后就先稍微暂缓了一下
稍微淡定一下
那个机器换一块电池
快撑不下去了
咱们这次就是为了拍节目嘛
也是来长沙了
那拍摄之余有没有到处逛一逛
没有没有时间
永远都是2.1线的
就是工作嗯
跟酒店对
因为其实就是每一个姐姐都很重视这个舞台
所以我前面可能有讲到的
我们线下的排练几乎也是天天
那至少也都是四五个小时
甚至会超过八个小时的这种排列
也有就是天天
所以大家其实呃可以好好感受一下长沙的那个美食跟风景的时间不多
但就是大部分是就是叫外卖的
但我平时说其实节目组其实是是照顾的蛮好的
比如说我们在点餐的时候可以点徐记海鲜
哪
还可以点那个港式
那叫什么稻香啊
呃就是一很好吃的这些餐厅
但是因为你知道吗
在那里天天中餐
晚餐都是吃这些的时候
就是当我们离开嗯录制的会展的时候
就这两家明明是很好吃的餐厅
就会想到嗯
可以先暂停一下下
就先暂停一下下
所以我们大部分其实都是叫外卖到到到酒店吃饭
那有没有吃到我们长沙的小吃呢
就是一定要吃的小龙虾啊
跟黑色的臭豆腐啊
对不对
但还好
其实我也蛮吃辣的哦
我还蛮吃辣的
所以其实这里的菜我都还蛮喜欢的
能不能稍微就是说一下
您最喜欢我们长沙什么菜
最喜欢的美食有吗
想一想最喜欢的辣椒小炒肉
辣椒炒肉对我好像最常点辣椒炒肉啊
其实我看你抖音都发了
你喜欢喝我们那个奶茶
我们茶那个甜品
喝奶茶
我看你还分享了喝法
很专业很厉害很专业
小得意一下好
那最后呢能不能就是对着镜头跟喜欢你的领导们说一些话喽
哈喽知道大家很想念我
所以这次来参加了乘风破浪三
然后有很多很不一样的舞台
我相信你们应该看得很开心吧
然后那乘风破浪现在还继续录制当中
你们敬请期待接下来的嗯好的舞台
然后所有的姐姐都很认真很努力
节目组也很用心
姐姐们很需要大家的支持和鼓励好吗
谢谢锋芒的小伙伴们
下次见喽